la page des sports du lundi à présent
avec anthony oui on va commencer donc
avec du rugby ce week-end le stade
français le racing s'affrontent sur un
terrain saint quentinois sur le terrain
du sky rugby justement il s'agit des
crabos et les reichel alors dit comme ça
on pourrait peut-être se croyait que
gilles régis savoie cette fois c'est du
rugby crabos et reichel oui tout à fait
il s'agit bien des meilleures divisions
nationales de jeunes de -19 ans et de
-21 ans et pour en parler avec nous sur
ce plateau lionel garrigues président du
sky rugby bonsoir bonsoir et olivier
laval vice président chargé de
l'événementiel bonsoir bonsoir alors
justement les relations vous pouvez nous
expliquer un petit peu ce concept de ba
de match de gala tout simplement alors
tout simplement sachez que depuis quatre
ans le saint quentin en yvelines rugby
est en collaboration avec le stade
français et donc nous avons le plaisir
dès le week-end prochain de perdurer
dans cette collaboration et notamment
avec l'accueil de match de niveau
effectivement comme vous le dites
nationales dans des catégories des
jeunes de moins de 20 ans et de moins de
19 ans donc c'est une première étape
cette collaboration arrive très tôt dans
cette nouvelle saison c'est le
calendrier qui s'y prête et nous allons
étendre par rapport aux années
précédentes notre collaboration vers
d'autres catégories également du stade
français ça veut dire que les joueurs
qu'on va voir évoluer à du côté d'el
encore mort pas ce week-end ce sont des
joueurs qu'on retrouvera dans des dans
les équipes seniors ensuite
éventuellement alors c'est déjà le cas
puisque les années passées à lens au
même rythme pour tout le monde nous
avons des jeunes qui ont été formés dans
nos écoles de rugby respectives qu'ils
sont effectivement dans ces catégories
là certains sont également dans les
espoirs du stade français ou du racing
et nous avons également de jeunes formés
au club qui sont professionnels dans le
top 14
monsieur briatte à brive et monsieur
payen aux grands clubs de toulouse non
on voit justement des images 1 2
l'édition précédente à bien et alors
justement par rapport à ce match de gala
c'est un échange qui va dans les deux
sens on sait pas ça peut simplement un
prêt de terrain voilà tout à fait c'est
une relation ce que je baptise de
gagnant gagnant le stade français a des
besoins de
deux places non disponibles dans ses
propres locaux donc nous avons ouvert
nos portes pour les accueillir et en
retour le stade français nous offrent
également des prestations donc nous
avons déjà un ramassage de bal prévu
pour le match stade français biarritz
pour nos jeunes nous avons effectivement
des invitations lors des grands matches
de gala au stade de france et samedi
nous avons également puisque ça va être
un week-end aux couleurs du stade
français l'école de rugby du stade
français qui vient pour un plateau
amical face à nos petits bambino mais
c'est la guerre entre les clubs
justement locaux dans les différents
départements pour attirer les petits
professionnels il ya aucune guerre
aucune logo pour skis et beaucoup de
clubs comme vous qu'il soit les
accueillir ces professionnels alors il
ya beaucoup de clubs qui est
effectivement à voir ces affiches là il
y à des collaborations qui sont par des
canaux des fois un petit peu plus
intimiste et privés pour rien vous
cacher que vous avez versé des
pots-de-vin pour acquérir ou pas du tout
vous savez la fierté je crois que c'est
de voir effectivement déjà le public
nombreux le public se rendre compte que
le rugby du 51è been rugby est proche de
celui du rugby national et de faire
effectivement découvrir à tous nos
jeunes notamment ceux rugby de haut
niveau dans lequel certains de leurs
aînés ils sont ce n'est pas un grand
rêve c'est une réalité
justement votre particularité c'est que
c'est un partenariat faut bien insister
là dessus parce qu'il ya d'autres clubs
qui sont en contrat avec le stade
français parce qu'on sait que de 7
français des gros problèmes de structure
pour accueillir tous ses matches alors
que vous vous êtes en partenariat donc
c'est vraiment gratuit à ce jour il
s'agit effectivement d'un partenariat
sous forme de prestations donnant
donnant gagnant gagnant comme vous
l'avait initié une tente devant le
président aussi comment ça s'est mis en
place comment vous avez réussi à faire
venir ses équipes sur le terrain de
genre déjà je suis bien accompagné oui
j'ai quelqu'un d'assez exceptionnel dans
le domaine j'en profite d'ailleurs pour
faire des remerciements à la mairie de
maurepas qui prête ses qui prête ses
installations donc c'est une vraiment un
succès qui se fait avec avec tous les
partenaires y compris enfin
particulièrement la mairie et le service
des sports alors comment on a été initié
effectivement ces gamins qui monte dans
ces grands stades ça crée des liaisons
préfère aussi une liaison avec toi je
peux faire une liaison avec alain gazon
dont on parlera tout à l'heure qui est
aujourd'hui sélectionneur au racing club
de france notamment sur la partie jeunes
et qui également donc quelqu'un qui va
nous prêter main-forte sept cette saison
en tant qu' en tant que directeur
sportif ou depuis l'école de rugby
jusqu'à nos seniors donc voila voila
comment se font les liens en fait la
famille du rugby se retrouve assez
facilement et spontanément
personnellement je ne me voyais pas un
jour sollicité alain gazon comme ça
parce que c'est quand même un grand
monsieur c'est celui qui a créé l'école
de rugby de massy et qui a créé fin
c'est l'âme de massy je peux le dire à
100 voilà et donc
quand j'ai regardé sollicité pour qu'il
vienne nous aider je n'en menais pas
large en fait un même si c'est quelqu'un
de très accessible c'est un périgourdin
comme moi ça peut-être facilité les
choses
n'ont pas beaucoup d'ambition on va
parler de l'aspect sportif du stade
j'allais y venir vous parler de l'équipe
senior justement monsieur monsieur
garrigue quelles sont les ambitions
cette année puisque vous êtes maintenant
un petit peu miraculeusement si j'ose
dire la saison dernière en division
d'honneur c'est vrai que l'on peut en
fait qualifié de miraculé parce que nous
avions devions simplement deux victoires
au compteur et un match nul mais
cependant la dernière nous avons perdu
nos matchs de de manière très très
faible qu'on a toujours eu des points
défensifs ont peur de 2.23 points ce qui
fait qu'on n'était pas vraiment un
niveau en dessous mais un dixième de
nice en préciser pour les non initiés
les points de bonus défensif en fait
c'est quand on perd par moins de dix
points d'écart récemment de sceller pour
moi merci soyons précis
donc voilà c'est comme ça qu
effectivement administrativement n'était
en été récupérés
ceci dit la cour la compétition se
durcit cela qu'aujourd'hui il ya trente
deux clubs en honneur dans deux ans ce
qui se profile c'est 20 clubs maximum
sur un sur l'honneur ça veut dire que la
sélection sera rude vous me posez la
question de nos ambitions elles sont
elles seront à la hauteur de sa timide
que nous impose un petit peu le haut
niveau même si nous ambitionnons pour
plus tard la fédérale 3 le maintien en
honneur et notre notre voeu le plus cher
cette saison et en plus à l'intersaison
il ya eu quelques changements dans
l'encadrement
on en parlait tout à l'heure
effectivement cédric cheveux qui était
un acteur essentiel du club en tant qu'
en tant que l'entraîneur avait fait
plusieurs années et il a eu une
proposition intéressante pour entraîner
dreux et puis on le renouvellement est
toujours quelque chose d'intéressant il
n'y a pas eu de on a perdu quelques
joueurs mais pas pour autant c'est pas
des joueurs qui sont partis à dreux
poursuivi l'entraîneur se sont ce sont
les aléas du rugby qui font que certains
joueurs sont plus tard parti soit vers
leur province soit dans d'autres clubs
mais et puis nous avons un apport de
nouveaux joueurs alain gazon participent
aussi les un petit peu à cette heure là
sur le recrutement et nous adapter peut
aller chercher des des forces vives
prochain match pour votre équipe fanion
et qu'il saigne à mes jours le 7 octobre
mort par donc contre le club de finances
qui est un vieux club parisien durant un
bon club avec une très belle école de
rugby aussi et donc avec des ambitions
pour ce club du saint-quentin rugby ça
quand on est bien au rugby et puis bien
sûr ce match de gala ces rencontres de
gala on en parlait il ya quelques
instants merci à tous les 2007 8e la
page jeux sports du lundi de ce 24
septembre ait du tennis à présent oui
tout à fait ce week-end y avait du beau
monde sur les sur les courts du
tennis-club de plaisir le club a
organisé ses traditionnels tournois
internationaux masculins et féminins et
les favoris français ont tenu leur rang
tout plaisir attendait les finales du
tournoi itf et futurs pas de chance
cette année il fallait surtout essayer
de ne pas s'endormir dans les tribunes
lors de la finale de ces dames au
concours du plus grand nombre de fautes
directes c'est la française iryna
brémond en noir et tête de série numéro
1 du tournoi qui s'en est sortis le
mieux peut-être lassé de mettre ces coup
droit dans le filet mais surtout blessé
au tendon d'achille elitsa kostova
abandonne 3 partout dans le second set
après avoir perdu le premier 6 jeux à 3
côté hommes la logique a été respectée
face au talentueux suisse de 21 ans
sandro il rate le français marc gicquel
habitué des tournois du grand chelem
fait jouer son expérience pour faire
craquer le joueur helvète dans les
points importants victoire nette et sans
bavure 6 3 6
j'ai fait un match solide j'ai bien joué
les moments importants je lé bien
retourner aussi quand il fallait gt gt
solide du début à la fin j'ai bien servi
pour finir et je me sentais vraiment
bien dans tous les compartiments du jeu
physiquement j'étais bien et donc une
semaine très très satisfaisante à côté
des professionnels les jeunes pousses
sont eux aussi le droit alors trophée à
l'issue des tournois jeunes organisait à
plaisir de quoi leur donner des envies
de gagner d'autres titres